remember the Pepsi challenge random
people would be blindfolded and taste
Coke and Pepsi and over 50% people would
always prefer the taste of Pepsi but
despite this to this day coca-cola
dominates Pepsi holding over double the
market share of Pepsi so why are Pepsi
sales worse than Coke even though the
product is better make sure stick around
to the end to find out welcome to Hari
saw bees so over the last decade Pepsi's
actually losing ground coca-cola
Coco lost market share has gone up from
seventeen point three percent to 17.8%
in the same time period Pepe's market
share went from ten point three percent
to 8.4 percent now Pepsi lover so sorry
that Pepsi is not that far behind encore
Cola but if you look at the market share
in sales numbers you definitely see
there's a drastic difference between
Coca Cola and Pepsi and this is
precisely why Pepsi launched the Pepsi
challenge in 1975 in an effort to gain
ground against Coca Cola Coke had been
number one for several decades and they
had a great distribution effective
marketing an outstanding brand loyalty
now pepsi wanna show that their product
was better and a Pepsi executive had a
revolutionary strategy to do just that
Pepsi would go inside malls around the
country and invite people to taste test
Coke and Pepsi and choose which one
tastes better I mean they had nothing to
lose going into this and as they started
conducting a test they realized that
Pepsi was actually preferred by the
majority of people they were clearly
onto something they continued to repeat
their tests to make sure that this was a
consistent results and after that they
started to make ads based off of this
there were several ads promoting
consumers to let their taste buds decide
and take the Pepsi challenge this was
very effective as many people did take
the Pepsi challenge even at home but
this didn't correlate to greater sales
so what happened well the first problem
was that Pepsi didn't follow up with
their brilliant keys they were
outstanding getting people to actually
try Pepsi but they failed at getting
people to actually buy Pepsi
they ended up with a lot of people who
thought that Pepsi tasted better but
didn't actually buy Pepsi on a regular
basis they had to make Pepsi a habit and
they couldn't then this in several
different ways they could have given
people who picked Pepsi as a superior
option a coupon for a case of Pepsi or
giving them a full free case of Pepsi
I'm a truck outside a mall or they could
have gotten their addresses and
periodically sent them coupons for a
free case of Pepsi maybe once every two
weeks for the first three months people
who weren't interested would simply
ignore the coupon and not even redeem it
but people who actually were interested
may actually start to purchase Pepsi on
a regular basis and giving you on six
cases it's not a lot of money for Pepsi
when compared to the amount of money and
they can make I'll follow a customer and
when you're giving out a free case of
Pepsi you're not only affecting the
person that you're giving it to
we're actually affecting their whole
network when their friends and family
come over they will probably try Pepsi
as well and this could spread really
really far so perhaps it took out one
more step past proving better taste they
could have been a lot more successful in
terms of market share by following up
with customers they could have captured
a lot more of the population but even if
they did this there will be a lot of
people who prefer Coke no matter what
and this was actually proved by
coca-cola themselves with the new coke
the Pepsi challenge actually made
coca-cola Blaine ervis and they started
to do press releases questioning the
legitimacy of the Pepsi challenge they
also started releasing ads saying that
Coco's better and the paranoia of Pepsi
and losing market share really got to
coke and as a result they launched new
coke which tasted more like Pepsi but
even better now coke isn't stupid I'm
sure that they conducted hundreds of
tests to make sure that the New Coke was
definitively better than old code they
were literally changing their best
selling product and I'm sure that they
were very confident on the new taste
before doing something so drastic and
while I'm assured that New Coke was
better than the classic
coke this did not stop new coke from
being disaster in the market people
didn't want a new coke in fact 400,000
letters were sent to coca-cola asking
for them to change it back he actually
listened to what their customers wanted
and brought back the original Cooke
calling it classic but they continued to
offer new coke now you would think that
this would make everyone happy and it
didn't make everyone happy but this was
terrible for the brand as a created
internal rivalry between new coke and
classic coke this was dividing their fan
base instead of uniting them to fight
against Pepsi so eventually they removed
new coke and there wasn't much
complaining about it and this shows that
coca-cola themselves couldn't beat their
original coke recipe this is not to say
that New Coke or Pepsi doesn't taste
bears in the classic coke but that
people simply just want classic coke now
Pepsi is sweeter than coke and as a
result many people say that people will
prefer Pepsi when you take it in small
samples but in terms of cans and
long-term drinking coca-cola is superior
now I don't agree with this at all as
research shows that 50% people can't
even correctly identify Coke and Pepsi
from a blind taste test maybe you can
and you definitively like one over the
other but as for the market as a whole
the difference in taste is not what is
causing the sales disparity as a result
even if Pepsi does slightly taste better
in Coke it really doesn't matter because
they are so similar in the first place
the fact that Pepsi tastes better is
only significant marketing on a day to
day basis people would be satisfied with
either drink and this is why I think
people continue to drink coke they
weren't convinced enough to completely
change your daily habits I don't think
that has to do with coke tasting better
and long-term but rather that they are
so similar to start off with and believe
it or not coke actually had better mural
marketing neuromarketing
is manipulating human behavior for
certain markets and by using the
advanced neuroimaging
tools that we have available today we
can discover pattern to neural activity
when people are choosing between two
brands or watching ads and this was
could attest by scientists Coke and
Pepsi were given blindly to one group of
people and to the other group of people
Pepsi and Coke were revealed there was
constant neural response when the Coke
or Pepsi was given anonymously but when
consumers knew which brand was their
newer activities significantly increased
specifically there are cerebral areas
related to cultural influences were
activated and brain scans revealed that
once a drink was revealed as Pepsi this
actually didn't change neural activity
but as for Coke portions of brain
related to emotions as well as cultural
influences were activated people were
actually more emotionally connected with
coke maybe this has something to do with
nostalgia what the researchers found was
that disconnection completely overrode
the actual taste of the product and this
once again gave coca-cola the advantage
and the final and harvesting for Pepsi
rubric was clueless insane brand loyalty
this could be because of more effective
marketing cultural influences or
nostalgia but whatever the reason Coke
did have better brand loyalty than Pepsi
and brand loyalty is very very hard to
break and takes a lot of time and money
and for a lot of people
you simply can't break it no matter what
you do and because of all of this
Pepsi could never overtake Coca Cola in
the soda market but despite that both of
the companies are corporate giants Pepsi
is actually almost the biggest Coca Cola
despite having less than half of the
market share in terms of soda and this
is because they have a lot more
diversified income they own several
other food companies like frito-lay
Tropicana and Quaker Oats and perhaps is
actually in a better position than
coca-cola as they are not as well and on
soda and maybe one day PepsiCo will
actually become more of a food company
than a soda company like Nestle you
really can't go wrong with Pepsi or coke
they're both great so this you'll be sad
tired either one but from a business
perspective
coca-cola has a stronger emotional
connection with its customers and better
brand loyalty as a result Pepsi
really can't compete even if they were
able to scientifically prove that their
product is the better tasting one but
this is actually alright for Pepsi and I
think they're happy with where they're
at in the market they have several other
revenue streams coming in and there are
almost as big as coca-cola and whatever
happens these two companies will pretty
much always be the market dominators in
terms of soda but that's why I call Cola
will always have an edge of market share
when compared with Pepsi but that's all
I have for you guys on a wide tasted
equal sales for Pepsi make sure comment
down below what company you would like
me to cover next also if you guys like
this view and drop a like and consider
subscribing if you don't see more videos
just like this one let's go then I'm
hearty I'll see you guys on the next one